ok today we're going to talk about
controlling fertility
we're going to look at methods to treat
infertility and we're going to look at
contraceptives as well so first of all
infertility or if you're infertile it
means that you can't reproduce naturally
now there might be several different
reasons for this but we're going to
learn about a couple of things which can
be done in case people are infertile so
the first one that we're going to learn
up learn about is clomiphene therapy now
what clone Athene therapy is is some
women don't ovulate so they don't
release their eggs naturally so as a
result this drug here called clong clong
Athene can release these cause the body
to release these two hormones FSH and LH
this stands for follicle stimulating
hormone and this stands for luteinizing
hormone now what this does is actually
the FSH travels in the blood because
it's a hormone it travels to the ovaries
and causes the eggs to mature and then
the LH the luteinizing hormone causes
ovulation
so clomiphene actually allows the eggs
to be released from the ovaries then
they could be fertilized by a sperm next
up the other way that we could use to
treat in to treat infertility is a
process called
IVF this stands for in vitro
fertilization so this is actually done
in a lab so what can happen is X cells
can be taken from the from the ovary
so there's a procedure to remove these
egg cells so the egg cells go into a
petri dish in a lab and then we can add
in the sperm cells within the lab so
we're actually the fertilization is
happening in vitro so that's happening
kind of in the lab now what happens is
what's fertilization has occurred
we form an embryo that's just the
developing ball of cells that will
become the fetus and then the baby so
once the embryo once we have the embryo
we could then put the embryo but into
the uterus here and then hopefully it
can implant in the wall here and the
baby can develop so that is how IVF
works in vitro fertilization okay so we
we can't just control infertility we
could also we could also use hormones as
a means of contraception
so what contraception means is
contraception is just a way of stopping
someone getting pregnant so the third
one we need to know about is if we have
progesterone so progesterone is a
hormone so there's kind of two main ways
that progesterone can be given one is in
the mini pill so this is just a pill
that can be taken orally so that's taken
by swallowing it on a kind of daily
basis and we also have the injection so
this is an injection that women can have
that contains progesterone so what does
this actually do so what progesterone
does is it causes a buildup in cervical
mucus cervical mucus now what this does
is actually means if there's all of this
mucus is build up in the set around the
cervix so around here it means that
sperm can't actually get through so it
means that the fertilization could not
happen because the sperm will not be
able to get to the oviduct to fertilize
the egg cell now that's one hormonal
method another hormonal method is called
the combined pill
now the combined pill this contains
progesterone but it also contains
estrogen so these are both hormones that
could be used in contraception so if
we've constantly got high estrogen
concentration it actually means the FSH
the FSH production is actually inhibited
so it's actually stopped now what this
means is the eggs do not mature and
therefore these eggs are not released
from the from the ovaries so that's the
action of East region but remember it's
combined which means it also contains
progesterone so it also produces this
thick cervical mucus that the sperm
cannot get through finally we need to
know about barrier methods we need to
know about barrier methods so the two
barrier methods we need to know about
are condoms and the female diaphragm so
all these are is a condom is latex
device that goes over the penis and it
literally acts as a barrier so the penis
enters here in the vagina if the person
is wearing condom over their penis it
means that the sperm are kind of a court
within the condom and they will not
reach the egg so it's just a physical
barrier it's a physical barrier just to
stop the sperm cells reach in the egg
also diaphragm the diaphragm is a device
that fits around here just just between
the vagina and the uterus so it fits
just below the cervix and it stops the
sperm being able to get through to the
egg cells so these are both barrier
methods
now the only one out of all of them the
only one that stops the spread of sti's
is the condom that is the only one out
of all of them and the negative side as
well about some of these hormones for
example using estrogen or progesterone
is it can really affect it can really
affect acne and it can also cause
problems with mood swings as well so
those are the different ways of
controlling infertility in kilometers
from a fiend for abhi and IVF and these
are the different ways of controlling
fertility these the hormonal methods
this is the barrier method remember
condoms are the only ones that prevent
the spread of sti's those what that
means sexually transmitted infections
thank you